A Pâques, c’est la tradition,
on cache des œufs en chocolat.
Alors du chocolat d’accord, c’est la fête,
mais pourquoi des œufs ?
Parce qu’autrefois les poules ne recommençaient
à pondre qu’au printemps,
quand il y a davantage de lumière.
Durant l’Antiquité, l’œuf était donc un symbole
de renaissance et de renouveau.
On en a même trouvé dans des tombes sumériennes, une ancienne civilisation du Moyen-Orient,
pour accompagner le défunt dans sa nouvelle vie.
Mais si l’œuf est devenu incontournable
en cette période de l’année
c’est parce qu’autrefois l’église en interdisait
la consommation durant le Carême.
40 jours pendant lesquels les poules
continuaient à pondre.
Le jour de Pâques, quand le jeûne prenait fin,
on offrait des œufs, symboles de renouveau
et de résurrection du Christ,
mais aussi pour vider les réserves
et remplir les estomacs.
L’œuf, le vrai, est un aliment très riche en protéines.
2 œufs correspondent à un steak de 100 grammes.
En chocolat, il n’a pas l’air mal non plus…
une vraie « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour. Alors pour ne rater aucune de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...